nothing that I've seen in my time as
mayor of Buffalo and nothing that I've
seen in my lifetime has come close to
what we've seen of the past couple of
weeks habit right here it has been nine
days sends a 75 year old man who
approached police in Buffalo New York
was pushed falling backwards to the
ground outside City Hall nine days of
convulsion and conversation for a city
that's become a new national flashpoint
when you first saw the video of Martin
Gugino being shoved down what did you
think I immediately thought about is he
going to be okay it was horrific
I was very worried for his health
immediately praying but then had to
reach out very quickly to the management
of the Buffalo Police Department to try
to make sense of what I had seen the
first report from Buffalo Police Ed
Martin Gugino tripped and fell what
happened in the initial communication
process where it was said that he he
tripped and fell well you know what I'd
like to say and what people are missing
is that people in every single
profession can make a mistake and that
mistake doesn't mean that an intention
to mislead is what occurred but it
wasn't corrected until the video
actually came out again everything
moving very quickly there were reports
that went globally with me that I called
mr. Gugino an agitator I never called
him an agitator when a protester is told
to clear an area and then doesn't and
walks up the police what are they
trained to do one of the things that
they're trained to do is use common
sense common sense wasn't used here
I don't believe common sense was used I
don't believe the push was necessary
officers though that were involved in
that incident do deserve their day in
court
like every American who is charged with
anything deserves their day in court
what do you think should happen to them
well I think what the police
commissioner did was appropriate after
the incident both officers were
suspended without pay and charged with
second degree assault in response all 57
members of the Special Response Unit at
Buffalo PD resigned from their group
though not from the larger force we lost
that unit because of a threat from the
Buffalo Police Benevolent Association
they got a bulletin from their union
saying that if you perform these duties
as a member of that unit you will not
receive coverage from the Union and I
think that that is unconscionable for a
union to treat 57 dues-paying members in
that way on Tuesday President Trump sent
the buffalo story to a whole new level
questioning whether Martin Gugino has
ties to antifa claiming he fell harder
than he was pushed the president asked
whether it was a setup similar
sensational comments have been made
about other cities Brown responded
immediately there have been different
different responses Seattle mayor
responded saying go back in your bunker
your response was was much more tempered
why I think we have to go out of our way
right now to show our respect and call
people into being part of the solution
and not do anything that can possibly
divide people even when others don't
show respect as a leader it's critically
important for me to model the behavior
that I want every single resident of
this community to exhibit this is just
the first step the day after the tweet
Mayor Brown held a news conference
announcing a series of reforms including
tickets not arrests for low-level
criminal offenses if the actions that
you took on Wednesday were so necessary
why weren't they done before it's just a
continuation of reforms that we've made
in the City of Buffalo the plan you
released does not include dismissing
officers with a history of brutality why
New York state law collective bargaining
laws in New York State do not allow us
to do that outside City Hall Thursday
how do I know I think you're telling the
truth right now where we watched a
handful of protesters confront Brown the
mayor is allowing people to write with
chalk on the city's most famous building
sometimes graphic messages yes I'm
pretty direct messages for the police
department here and we're fine with that
because these messages can be removed in
the initial round of protests the city's
residents watched as one man threw a
burning object through a city hall
window
he was arrested the next day and Brown
says he'll be fully prosecuted so get
ready because we're coming all while
protesters gather not just outside the
mayor's place of work but his home
you've got white protesters holding
black lives matter signs outside your
house when you see that what's your
reaction I am glad that people finally
realize after 400 years in this country
that black lives matter why did it take
the death of George Floyd to have some
of these conversations it was a
flashpoint it was just a continuation of
things that we've seen in this country
before Eric garner of Brianna Taylor
Freddie gray Ahmad our burry and the
anger the frustration just bubbled over
they all have been painful they all have
been distressing this took on a life of
its own it's been played over and over
and over again when my family and I
first watched that together there were
tears in my house
I almost feel it now just thinking about
it I see that is this a process that
takes a lot longer than most people
think I think it is a process that will
take longer than most people think but
it's a process that has to be approached
with a listening ear with an open heart
and with great urgency